welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast right now
the kovat 19 pandemic is having huge
effects all over the world so first and
foremost the stronger by science family
sincerely hopes that you are safe and
healthy and doing well it's obviously
very important to stay informed about
what's going on but right now the Cova
19 news is pretty bleak and it's also
everywhere so what we would like to do
is make sure that our podcast is a place
where you can kind of get away from
covet 19 and focus on virtually anything
else for that time with that in mind
Greg and I want to use this episode to
basically give you all the useful
information we have to share that might
relate to kovat 19 and basically move
away from the topic entirely moving
forward so for today's episode we are
going to talk about how different
health-related habits can impact your
immune system we're going to talk a
little bit about how to structure an
at-home workout with little or even no
equipment whatsoever and then after that
we are going to move on to other topics
so we're going to introduce a good news
segment where we just share some
positive news which everybody could use
right now and then we do a lot of Q&A
this episode so in the Q&A is we filled
a whole bunch of questions on topics
including optimal protein intake lifting
with long limbs eating to support injury
prevention benchpress range of motion
fat burners and more to play us out
gregg share some information about how
to make risotto and then I add a couple
extra tips to take your risotto to the
next level as always thanks for
listening and enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by signs podcast this is your
very permanent host Eric Trexler and I'm
joined by a very temporary guest host
named Greg knuckles thanks for having me
thank you for joining me so a long time
ago we talked a little bit about the
schedule for the podcast right we
mentioned we were going to be taking a
summer break and we looked at the
calendar realize that we were coming up
on it and we are just a little bit
behind on cue A's
there are a ton of questions I don't
know how many it would probably give me
give me anxiety to count it but there's
a lot of questions to get to and so for
today's episode we are going a little
bit off format swapping out some of the
the typical segments that we do in
answering a lot of your questions from
the list so as you all know what's the
link for people to send questions it's a
tiny tiny CC slash SBS QA yes so if you
want to add your questions to the list
that's where you do it but one of the
big focal points for today is we do want
to knock out a bunch of the questions
that are on there before we do that so
you're getting news everywhere about the
coronavirus it's not good news
and so what we want to do is we want the
podcast to be a place where you can
basically not think about the
coronavirus for a couple hours but there
are I mean whether or not it's good news
kind of depends on your general views
regarding social darwinism we are mostly
of the opinion that it's overall not
good news but we're not gonna yak you're
young yeah sure so what we want to do is
there are a couple things we wanted to
say related to you know how the
coronavirus affects you how you might be
able to kind of adjust your fitness
plans accordingly but basically once we
get through that we want to just move
the hell on and not talk about it here
and so we're gonna have a little quick
coaches corner about that today because
a lot of people are going through gym
closures right now and they're like
okay how do I still salvage Salvage my
my fitness goals my fitness plans so
we're gonna talk about that and then
move on and moving forward we don't want
to commit too strongly to anything here
but we are thinking that we're probably
going to record some like extreme like
way more off-topic podcasts compared to
normal
kind of like short short audio sessions
where we just talk about some fitness
stuff and some non fitness stuff way
less structured than our typical podcast
with different segments so we're not
sure how many we're gonna do we're not
sure how long they're gonna do or how
long they're gonna be but if you have
any questions that are completely off
topic that you want us to chat about
feel free to send them to us just
wherever you know set them on Facebook
Instagram do you have a specific place
that you want them I mean you can submit
them just at tiny CC slash SBS QA but
yeah I mean just messaging them to us
would probably be better we recently put
out a call on Facebook and Instagram
asking for off-topic questions like 90
percent of the questions we got were
still how do I work out with a home gym
so I mean like we're gonna get a bunch
of those questions so try to make them
as off topic as possible
anything yeah so just like anything
you're generally interested about or
interested in that is not Fitness
related we know you guys have other
interests you absolutely have to have
other interests so assuming you do
something other than work and go to the
gym or now you know go to work and work
out in your apartment or home ask
questions about or ask questions or
suggest topics related to those sorts of
things yeah I mean and I might as well
just be completely transparent about the
impetus for some of these other episodes
basically I was working the other day in
my apartment I love to listen to spoken
word stuff when I'm working I usually
just turn on some talk radio listening
to the news and I'm gonna be honest the
other day I was like I cannot stomach
the news it is the last thing I want to
hear right now and I would love for
there to be something that's kind of
just fun and chill and I mean let's be
honest most of us are socially isolated
anyway these days you know like I hang
out with Greg and my girlfriend and
Lindsay and that's it
you know so we're thinking like it'd be
great if we can record something that
was a thing people could listen to enjoy
it
not think too hard not have the weight
of the world on their shoulders and it'd
basically be us hanging out and just
inviting you along for the ride so if
you would like to hang out with us we'd
love to have you ask us some questions
listen along it should be very laid-back
in chill anything to add no that's about
it we want those segments the theme of
them to be good vibes only so if you're
interested in good vibes
check out those episodes yeah and we're
gonna name them differently I don't know
how we're gonna name them but it'll be
obvious what they are okay you want to
dive into stuff we got we got a coach's
corner coming up here let's do it okay
so coaches corner we wanted to talk a
little bit about supporting immune
function because it's on a lot of
people's minds we're not gonna sell you
a special supplement or a ridiculously
short ebook we're just gonna tell you
stuff that actually makes sense a little
bit about immune function and a little
bit about how to adapt your training if
you've got a gym closure and mope I mean
a lot of people do you know I can't tell
you how many of my clients in the last
72 hours
you know gym shut down so let's start
with immune function and you're gonna
notice we said supporting immune
function we didn't say you know
supercharging or boosting because
there's basically a set of habits you
can do to reinforce proper immune
function and that's really the best we
can do you know we can try to maintain
some decent habits and make sure that
we're not shooting ourselves in the foot
when it comes to our immune systems
function so we don't want to oversell it
but you know there is quite a body of
research indicating a variety of things
that you that you can do to keep your
immune system functioning properly Greg
you want to start us off there yeah so
one of the first things you're you're
gonna want to do is to the greatest
degree possible
try to make sure you're sleeping well so
that includes both sleeping enough and
trying to maintain a consistent
circadian rhythm you know normal
sleep-wake cycle if you're stressed it
can be difficult to fall asleep you
might be more likely to wake up in the
middle of the night that's you know
that's something that can happen if you
stress out about that that then makes
sleeping even more challenging so you
know don't don't freak out about it but
do try to sleep as much as you can if
you're isolated indoors something that
can help is still try to get up around
the same time in the morning you
typically would to try to maintain that
consistency or Cayden rhythm if you're
doing work from home or just chilling
out at home under quarantine try to
spend a fair amount of the morning near
when near windows so you can get you
know morning blue-tinted light into your
eyes that helps with with regulating
your circadian rhythm and then just all
of all of the other various things we've
recommended before on the podcast to
help with sleep so try to you know wake
up and go to bed at a consistent time
try to make sure that your bedroom is
cool but not cold have a consistent
bedtime routine that helps you wind down
all of those things will help you sleep
better and you know it's not like it's
not like you can sleep 14 hours a day
and that's going to make your immune
system impervious to everything but not
sleeping enough can certainly hinder
immune function definitely and you know
another thing to keep in mind is just
stress in general you know so you
mentioned stress can obviously affect
your sleep but the stress itself in many
cases is you know taken to the extreme
not great for immune function so that
involves both psychological stressors
but also physical stressors so one of
the things that we mentioned I believe
we mentioned it last episode is the fact
that when people undergo particularly
arduous fitness tasks like when one of
the common examples is marathon running
it's not atypical to hear about people
when they're either doing in
cute bout of exercise that's really
arduous or if they are really
overtraining and chronically kind of
overreaching what I don't want to use
those terms lightly but if they're in a
pretty serious overreaching phase and in
creating quite a recovery deficit it's
not atypical to see people acquiring
just little illnesses that they
otherwise might be able to fight off you
know we see a little bit of a
suppression of immune function in some
of those circumstances so managing your
stress and again not just thinking
psychological stressors but also
physical stressors making sure that
whatever training you're doing you're
really budgeting in time for recovery
and managing your overall training load
yeah for sure I mean so we're gonna talk
about you know if you can't make it to
the gym how you can still get in good
effective workouts at home but for the
time being this is probably not so one
this isn't time to just take off and not
exercise at all continuing to exercise
will again help support healthy immune
function so you don't want to just sit
on the couch all day that'll also it's
just no fun don't do that okay I mean
your psychological health like gonna be
good but but at the same time don't
think oh I'm not working right now like
they're telling me I can't go into work
so I'm just gonna train like a madman in
my apartment and do like push-ups and
bodyweight squats for six hours a day
that's also probably not the best thing
to do so the name of the game is you
know you want to still be training hard
enough that you're accomplishing
something
but maintenance or slight gains are kind
of the name of the game right now you
don't want to just crank your workouts
up to 11 this is not the time for that
right and then one other thing to talk
about is the nutrition side so you know
there's there's a lot of people pushing
supplements right now which is really
gross just with you know the really
ridiculous claims that are like super
specific to coronavirus it's like come
on dude there's not even a chance that
their science to support that there is
no science what are you talking about
you know but um but you know general
good nutrition habits may
ensure that you don't have any glaring
you know vitamin or mineral deficient
seams making sure you've got all your
bases covered when it comes to your
overall nutrient intake and another
thing is making sure you have at least
reasonably adequate caloric intake and
we were talking earlier you mentioned
you know weight loss for obese people
probably fine to continue you know with
those weight loss goals you know but if
you're already pretty lean probably not
the best time to go into like a super
huge deficit and try to get like
absolutely shredded that that's what
you're mentioning earlier yeah so just
to give credit where it's due
salt Orwell was the person who who put
this on my radar
he said we should write an article about
this I don't know that there's enough
research to kind of warrant a full
article but he sent me some stuff that
he said would be worth addressing to
just get the information out there if
you are if you are quite overweight
being in a moderate calorie deficit
doesn't really seem to have any
meaningful impact on immune function but
weight loss and especially pretty
aggressive caloric deficits if you're
already normal weight or like fairly
lean already can hinder immune function
to some degree so you know if you're if
you're on a cut right now and you're a
little fluffy you don't have to worry
about it if you're already kind of lean
and you're just kind of very gradually
trying to lean out that's probably okay
too but don't think hey you know I don't
have that many obligations on a
day-to-day basis anymore now is the time
to cut my calories to 1,200 into a
protein sparing modified fast that is
that is probably not recommended if
you're trying to support healthy immune
function
yeah and I'll say anecdotally because
you know my background I started as a
wrestler and then I became a natural
bodybuilder wrestling it was something
you always kept an eye out you know the
kids that were cutting weight super hard
they just always seemed to get whatever
bug was going around with bodybuilding
again when you're going from lean to
just shredded and eating just stupidly
low calories it's
that you have to keep on your radar is
you know just the little colds and flus
that go around so generally speaking not
I know this is gonna be a tough pill to
swallow but your body doesn't want to be
5 percent body fat and barely eating and
believe it or not that can have effects
on your immune system so you know what
we just what we just laid out there not
a compelling ebook don't know what kind
of powder we could turn that into for a
profit I gotta be honest I'm really
grossed out by a lot of stuff I see
right now with people just like
capitalizing on this fear but we're
gonna leave it at that are we though I
think we are so here's what I'm gonna
say here's all I want to say we can edit
this out if it goes too far just don't
mention any by my name I'm not going
okay so the stuff the stuff with
supplements I agree with your assessment
that is just completely gross and even
like stuff that has been potentially
shown to have some applications in in
some circumstances we can't know if any
of that applies to coronavirus so like
for example there's some research
showing that if you take a garlic
supplement or you have high levels of
garlic intake that slightly reduces your
risk of catching and common cold but
like dude one it's a it's a completely
different category of virus I was gonna
give a list it's it's one thing we have
no [ __ ] idea if that applies to
coronavirus and that and that applies to
anything that anyone is chilling right
now so like the supplement stuff is
gross and then like dude like you said
we have seen a few people trying to sell
how to not get coronavirus ebooks so one
if you're not working in a medical
profession like if you're not an
infectious disease expert you don't
[ __ ] know and also this [ __ ] blew up
what maybe a month maybe two months ago
if you were someone really following the
news out of China you haven't done
sufficient reading to be able to put a
product
like that together even if there is
potentially relevant research out there
one and then two
like dude you [ __ ] through the [ __ ]
together in two months no matter what
you're trying to sell one it's gross
that you're trying to sell it if you
think it's that important
just give it out to people like this
isn't the time to profit maximize and -
it's gonna suck like it's gonna [ __ ]
suck you haven't had time to put a good
product together well so so on one hand
it is very ethically slimy
and - it's gonna be a dog [ __ ] product
like capitalizing on fear is is bad in
the general sense but then you're
capitalizing on fear with utter [ __ ]
is even worse so just like make note of
who is doing that and never do business
with them again yeah and I should
clarify I wouldn't say that it's you
know there's nothing wrong with you know
the fact that a person might write
something about here are habits to help
with your immune system and maybe they
wrote it a year ago and it's like a
general thing or maybe they have some
kind of general immune supporting
supplement that that's not inherently
bad it's more like the messaging yeah
yeah the thing that the thing that we're
really really cat that really catches
our eye the wrong way is when people
very specifically linked that to
coronavirus and are pushing it right now
like honestly when the World Health
Organization tells me something about
coronavirus my responses I'm not sure if
you guys are totally sure about that
because they're they're honest they're
like uh preliminary thing coming out
maybe it's true seems like these are
some observations right so if the World
Health Organization is putting like
ninety five caveat on everything that
comes out aside from wash your hands it
really makes me wonder exactly how many
nuggets are hidden in that special ebook
you know what I mean like yeah and by
the way just to be abundantly clear I'm
not saying to be skeptical of the
information coming from from large
national international health bodies but
I'm reflecting the confidence of their
statements you know you've seen their
statements when they're like
no we've been trying this treatment it
seems okay but like everyone
acknowledges there is no peer-reviewed
science because I mean you could put a
preprint out there but there's no I mean
are there any papers that have actually
gone through review yet there have been
a couple but it's like it's expedited
yeah and it's more like so I mean this
very well may be different by the time
this episode comes out but there have
been a handful of papers that are just
generally trying to characterize right
yeah the disease itself yeah and there
there are a couple preprints like you
mentioned about some drug therapies that
are showing some degree of promise yeah
but it's not like a botanical extract
like we're talking about this stuff that
actual medical bodies are showing
interest in to treat this thing yeah
it's probably not [ __ ] you're gonna be
able to get your hands on
turns out watermelon juice who knew yeah
it's not really how it works yeah but no
I mean it's okay I think we've said
enough about it right I let's move on a
little bit and talk about how to
basically make the most of this right so
a lot of people going through gym
closures and I think a lot of people
they associate their strength goals
their performance goals their physique
goals with being in a physical
brick-and-mortar gym and I think when
you hear that gym access is gone you're
like okay well that's that's a dead end
right but yeah but there's a lot of
stuff that you can do at home right even
if you don't have a home gym correct
yeah yeah that's a that's a big a big
caveat there so Greg I guess the first
question is so someone's interested in
basically they don't have a home gym and
they're not able to swing it right now
you know they can because that's not
really a solution is be like oh can't
get to the gym build one like but yeah
that's great for like five people yeah
like that's another thing that has been
urging me a little bit where folks are
just like oh your gym closed that's fine
just by a power rack and barbell and a
bunch of hired and the thing is like I
have that it's great it's in my garage
it's awesome I love it
but in terms of just like putting that
out as like a general recommendation to
everyone in your Instagram audience
that's um I don't I don't want to be too
judgmental and call it like elitist
bougie wash it but the thing is like
most people don't have an empty garage
don't have an empty room in their house
and don't have I mean even a cheap racks
gonna run you a couple hundred bucks
even if you get like the cheapest
barbell they sell on Amazon that's
probably gonna be like a hundred bucks
or so good barbells gonna run you 250
300 plates even if you're buying them
used generally go for about fifty cents
a pound give or take and so even if
you're just outfitting the most
bare-bones home gym possible which again
if you can afford and you have the space
for it I think is awesome but that that
is that is a very non negligible expense
and it's not something that that you
should really be able to expect of
everyone right yeah you know there there
are you know a ton of people who have
home gyms there's certainly nothing
wrong with that it's not like it makes
you some like ultra elite billionaire
right to have a home gym yeah it when I
hear that advice just kind of getting
pushed out as if it's no big deal I feel
like that's saying like don't like
cooking here's a life hack hire a chef
yeah yeah it's more like when it's when
its package is just like a very flippin
thing yeah it's like oh you don't have a
grand that you can spend on the drop of
a dime haha peasant like yes yeah okay
so so Greg we're if we're not going to
build a home gym what are some of the
things that that you can get on like a
really a really small budget where you
could be like okay how do we get a
couple items that really maximize what
we can do at home yeah so first things
first the cheapest thing is free and
there's a lot of stuff you can do
absolutely for free so upper body
training and especially like a quote
unquote push training so pecs and
triceps very easy to train those muscles
at home so you can do push-ups if you
have a table or a counter you can stand
back from that put your hands on the
edge and like do skull Crusher's you can
do any number of push
variations if push-ups are super easy
for you you can elevate your feet to
make them a little bit harder you can
put your hands on books or stools or
something to extend the range of motion
to make them a little bit harder so
there's a lot of stuff you can do for
pecs and triceps very very simply cannot
can I add one thing there yeah go for it
you mentioned adding books I've been
doing a lot of uneven push-ups in recent
months where I basically would put like
maybe a stack of books under one hand
but not the other
mm-hm and I would do these at the gym I
would like I had access to all the
machines you'd want an ID something like
not give me a stack of stuff and I'd do
these uneven push-ups the stretch you
get in the pack oh yeah he's insane I
mean I was dying there was there was no
machine in the gym that was gonna give
me that I mean it was great dude it's
sick it's it's like the same thing as
dumbbells but like you know your
scapular is still pinned when you're
doing dumbbells so it'sit's the same
benefit but you can still have full
scapular movement yeah and I mean like
so I've also seen some hot takes on
Instagram like oh like push-ups are fine
for these plebs but like I'm a super
elite bencher like it's not enough for
me [ __ ] that it's not like dude we're so
with the caveat that training can be
high rep enough that it's not
necessarily ideal for hypertrophy so
there's there's some research showing
that down to about 30-40 percent 1rm as
long as you're pushing sets to failure
on a per set basis hypertrophy is gonna
run its course and be good once you get
down into like the 20% range which you
know is stuff you can probably do for 50
75 plus reps then you know it's it's
starting to become different from
resistance exercise and so hypertrophy
isn't gonna be maximized so like one you
probably aren't doing 70 push-ups per
set through a good full range of motion
but let's assume you are dude just do
like single arm push-ups
those are hard if you're knocking out
multiple sets of like 30 single arm
push-ups through a full range of motion
you're [ __ ] strong like that that no
matter how good of a venture you are I
almost guarantee that you can't do just
routine one-arm push-ups for dozens of
reps per set and if you can then maybe
the complaint of Oh push ups aren't
enough applies but otherwise you can you
can get a lot done with push-ups as far
as like upper back training and like
quote-unquote pole training goes here
you have to be a little bit more
creative you can do it with with just
bodyweight but it's not going to be as
easy as training pecs and triceps so if
you have decent fingers fingertip
strength you can do pull-ups on a
doorframe that's something that climbers
do a lot which again you do need pretty
decent fingertip strength for it for
that a classic is table rows so you just
get under a table
you grab the lip of a table you do rows
up to that one thing to be a little bit
careful about with table rows is you'll
probably want to put a counterweight on
the other end of the table just to make
sure you don't flip it onto yourself but
just due to how torque works if you put
a reasonable amount of weight on the
other end of the table it's gonna be
stable it's gonna be fine if you are
cooped up in the house with someone else
you can do buddy rows so you know you
you lay between the other person's legs
and basically do rows up into their
crotch if it's a significant other
that's fine if it's you know like a
roommate or something you'll get to know
each other better that's okay and then
for extremely low cost if you can get
like a gallon jug or I don't know what
they sell what increments they sell jugs
in and in places that don't use imperial
but assuming you have like four or five
litre jugs or something like that fill
it up with water a gallon of water I
believe is eight point two eight pounds
give or take somewhere around eight
pounds so you know it's gonna be high
reps but you can do curls with that if
it's leaders then however many leaders
it is if you fill it up with water it's
gonna be that many kilos and if there's
a store nearby that sells five
gallon jugs of water that's gonna be
like 40 pounds which you know there if
you're super super strong that may not
be enough weight but for most people
listening to this that's gonna be plenty
of weight for Rose and also I like delt
raises so yeah those would be some
recommendations for a very very small
investment in money if you can get one
of those over the door pull-up bars that
suddenly makes upper back training super
super easy you know you can now do
pull-ups looks like you're gonna say
something well I was thinking I don't
they don't they also have pull-up bars
that you can put like within the
doorframe instead of over the top
because I was thinking if you could set
something up like that for rows that
would be pretty nice I don't trust those
yeah well I yeah the the potential
downside is pretty obvious yeah so they
say they operate on the assumption that
you can generate enough tension I think
there's like a twist apart mechanism and
it puts tension against either side of
the door yeah I have seen too many
people fall off actually I've seen a lot
of those videos yeah yeah that's a good
point so yeah if you get a if you get a
over the door pull-up bar pull up
suddenly become incredibly easy if
you're somewhere where you're still
allowed to go outside and you have a
tree nearby you can do pull-ups on a
tree branch you know if it's in public
people may look at you weird but I mean
whatever it's fine those people don't
matter
you can do pull-ups on a tree branch
it's perfectly okay the only thing that
is considerably more challenging if
you're you know just trying to do home
workouts and either don't have any
equipment or only want to buy very very
minimal equipment is lower body training
so in terms of stuff you can do with
just bodyweight the idea that comes to
mind for most people immediately is
bodyweight squats and I will note if
you're squatting down to a full range of
motion and only coming back up to what
would essentially be your sticking point
with a normal
bell squat those do get pretty hard
pretty quick like I mean if if you're in
decent kind of like local aerobic shape
with your quads and hip extensors you
might be able to bust out a set of a
hundred but if you just give it a shot
and you've never done it before it's
gonna start burning pretty bad by
probably somewhere between 30 and 50
reps give or take so you can get some
mileage out of that something like a two
leg glute bridge is probably going to be
super easy to do for an enormous number
of reps but make it single leg it
suddenly becomes considerably more
challenging you'll be able to train your
glutes that way as far as quad training
goes split squats are good you can do
those for a bunch of reps they're gonna
be a lot harder than bilateral
bodyweight squats if you have a place
where you can do lunges even if it's
just back and forth across a room high
weight one or higher up lunges are
absolutely killer so again you won't be
able to load them super heavy with just
bodyweight obviously but they can be
quite challenging then I think the I
think maybe the most slept on bodyweight
lower body exercise is high step ups so
if you have if you have stuff in your
house that is just of various different
heights if you do a step up where like
the thing you're stepping up and down
off of is say below knee height it's
probably gonna be fairly easy so if
you've done step ups before you probably
don't realize just how much assistance
you're getting from the down leg and
just using your calves to push back up
off the ground but if you do if you do
step ups and for each rep all you do is
tap your heel to the ground keep your
knees straight and don't use your
non-working leg to help you at all even
like a pretty low step up can get pretty
challenging so I taught some weight
training classes the past couple years
when I was in grad school and there were
some people and there were some people
in the class who were just kind of like
nervous of lower body training so like
the leg
machine intimidated them they didn't
want to put the bar on their back and do
squats maybe they had some experience
with like split squats or bodyweight
squats from like fitness classes they've
done before and those were pretty easy I
introduced them to strict step ups and
that humbled a lot of people really
quick and you can get good you can get
surprisingly effective training with
just bodyweight doing step ups and so
like I said fairly low step ups can be
fairly challenging if you're doing them
strict as the height of the thing you're
you're stepping up on or lowering
yourself down off of goes up the
challenge increases dramatically so if
you can get to the point that you can do
really really strict step ups where
again you're just tapping your heel to
the ground not getting any assistance
from your down leg where your working
leg is going through the same range of
motion or a longer range of motion than
it would go through on squats you're
pretty strong by that point like those
are hard
those are legitimately hard no matter
how strong you are and then the other
thing you can do with just bodyweight
for lower body training similar to step
ups as pistols so just single leg squats
a lot of people don't have good enough
ankle mobility to do legitimate pistols
and if that's the case that's fine you
can probably still do partials so
basically like box squats but with
pistols where you know you start on a
chair and then if there's something a
little bit lower so maybe your couch is
a little bit lower than a chair then you
do it down to a couch and if you can't
go all the way down like you know maybe
you are just doing partials but pistols
are also shockingly difficult for a lot
of people and so there are a few other
things on our list that you can do if
you have access to just a little bit
more equipment but with access to just
your bodyweight and like some water jugs
you can train most parts of your body
pretty effectively the only things that
are going to be potentially left out
there is there's not anything great
there for hamstrings although I should
note if there if you have something that
you can use to anchor your feet to the
or again if you're cooped up with
someone else a roommate a romantic
partner whatever if they're willing to
hold your ankles you can do Nordic
hamstring curls if you've never done
those before prepare for a world of pain
they will [ __ ] murder you brutal so
again if you have if you have something
to secure your ankles you can train your
hamstrings pretty well also so really
the only muscle groups that are a little
bit more challenging to train with no
equipment or very very minimal equipment
is your traps which if you have those
five gallon jugs you can just do a ton
of light shrugs with like 40 pounds and
it's gonna get hard after a while but
that really is an ideal so traps are a
little bit more challenging and then
your spinal erectors without external
loading it is quite a bit more
challenging to train your your spinal
erectors unfortunately but most of your
body you can train just fine also so I
was kind of like going head to toe
trying to get everything in my head just
now I forgot I didn't mention calves
I love calf training I've talked about
this on the podcast before calf training
is great if you have a step or just
anything you can elevate your foot up on
just bodyweight strict single leg calf
raises can also be absolutely humbling
so go all the way down at the bottom get
a deep stretch you want to be holding on
to something so you don't lose your
balance but you don't use your upper
body to assist you at all get a deep
stretch and then control it on the way
up you don't want to just use spring
from your Achilles tendon you want to
actively contract your calf coming up
then hold that contraction for about a
second control yourself on the way down
deep stretch control on the way up
squeeze like I mean it depends how much
you weigh that's a very bodyweight
dependent thing but you know sets of 30
40 of those are gonna be able to get to
get most people a pretty good calf
stimulus as well so again traps are
challenging spinal erectors are
challenging
everything else really really isn't that
hard to train with just body weight or
very very minimal equipment and if
somebody was gonna take that next step
when it comes to equipment you know you
mentioned like just gallon jugs or
multiple gallon jugs if you can find
them are good
you mentioned the pull-up bar bands
obviously are a good option if you're
looking to expand what you can do a
little bit another thing like there's
the the TRX or any kind of suspension
system like that those can really open
up what you can do in terms of your
exercise selection and you know I have
some clients that were like dude gym is
completely closed we're screwed and I
was like okay well what do we have
sitting in the garage and they're like
well some adjustable dumbbells up to 90
and I'm like dude we have a gym like if
you if you could get like a just a set
of adjustable dumbbells like if you're
going from 10 to 90 you can get a lot
done because I mean every little tool
you add on it is just extra like you
said body weight alone can take you very
very far you know your cardio plans are
totally unencumbered in most cases my
understanding is you know most health
organizations aren't necessarily saying
you can't go outside in some cases but
don't congregate with other people keep
distance obviously some places are in
like total lockdown and that's not the
case but but but a lot of people you
know you can still go outside and go for
a jog alone or you know without a group
of people but yeah adding just a couple
little things on a really small budget
you can really open up a lot of
exercises and we are going to have a by
the time of this podcast airs will
probably have an article out what don't
you think I would think so we should be
able to get and by then yeah so we're
working on an article that kind of puts
all these ideas together when it comes
to bodyweight exercises so if you're
listening to this
check out the website is probably up
there already and if it is we've
certainly shared it on social media so
did you have anything else you wanted to
add for that segment yeah I think
there's more to say about
bans okay yeah go fun so I was I was
powerlifting during the peak of the
Westside era so I have I have a lot of
experience with bands and I think I
think current lifters who didn't kind of
go through the band craze just don't
understand just how flexible bands can
be so virtually any exercise that one
might do on a machine one can do with
bands anything that's reasonably heavy
that you can use to anchor bands gives
you an angle at which you can do an
exercise so if you have so I talked
about how push-ups can be made very
difficult with just bodyweight if you
don't want to mess around with single
arm push-ups or anything like that if
you have some reasonably heavy bands
they can supply 1 to 300 pounds of
tension you can you can do band resisted
push-ups just like bench press and like
don't try to flex and say that that's
not good enough for me like I've been
very close to 500 pounds so if I have
access to ideally a monster band but if
not a monster then either too strong
bands or a strong band and an average
band using like the old-school jump
stretch bands that is that is hard
enough to train benchpress for me like
it the movements feel slightly different
because it's not like a linear
resistance curve so it is going to be a
little bit harder at the top a little
bit easier at the bottom but it feels
pretty comparable to a bench press and I
can I can comfortably get enough band
resistance to where sets of 5 to 8 reps
of band resistant push-ups are hard so
you can make upper body training very
very easy if you're someone who you know
you're used to doing weighted push-ups
and you know you don't have a weight
belt and a bunch of plates at home you
can do band resistant push-ups if so if
you have a belt like just just a normal
a spelt or even like a piece of rope and
something to anchor a band to on the
ground you can attach the band to your
belt and use band resistance for
pull-ups that's going to be very
challenging should be enough for
Trulli anyone no matter how good you are
at pull-ups as long as you have enough
band tension and then like I said before
probably the most challenging muscles to
train without access to external
resistance and a gym setup are gonna be
your spinal erectors so one of the
things you can do if you have access
again to not just like little Thera
bands that you might use to rehab a
rotator cuff muscle but like legit
lifting bands dude you can just do
squats and deadlifts so the easiest
thing is gonna be band resistance squats
or like band resistant band resisted
good mornings to Train deadlifts but you
can just get a bunch of band tension you
stand on on one end of the band so you
like you stand within the band and your
feet are holding it down and then you
squat down you get the rest of the bands
you put them across your shoulders so
around where you put the bar for a low
bar squat you hold the bands to make
sure they stay in place and then you can
just do squats and you can do good
mornings so there are there are cheap
bands that you can get off of like
Amazon that are that are gonna be quite
a bit cheaper but for for I think like a
hundred and fifty bucks give or take
which again isn't cheap but isn't crazy
crazy expensive
I know elite FTS sells a band set which
I believe is a mini band a light band an
average band and a heavy band so so a
pair of each of those so eight bands
total and a pair of each of those
resistances if you add up how much total
resistance you can get out of just to
that set of eight bands on the little
like band - resistant conversion chart
they have on the site that's like I
think it's six hundred and forty nine
band or six hundred and forty nine
pounds of band resistance which dude if
you can bust out like sets of 30 squats
with that then like you know you're
probably Ray Williams and probably don't
listen to this podcast but virtually
anyone else listening to this if you
just have that band set you can now do
morning's training a similar motor
pattern as as deadlifts would and you
could do squats and they're [ __ ] hard
I trained like that for an entire summer
of my life actually so I went to to a
nerd camp one time it's it's a long
story we weren't allowed off of the site
and there wasn't a gym on site and so I
just took my band set and I so at the
end of that summer I was slightly weaker
than when I went just because I didn't
have access to a bar and like the motor
pattern and the resistance curve is
slightly different so I lost I lost like
some crispness under a barbell but
within like two weeks I was hitting PRS
so like I was getting stronger in a
general sense the motor pattern was
slightly different so it didn't transfer
perfectly as soon as I could get back
under the bar but for ten weeks it was
productive training and like I said
within two or three weeks I was hitting
PRS again so with just bodyweight
you're pretty set your back might get a
little weaker your traps might get a
little weaker but overall you can get
the job done if you get a pull-up bar
upper back training becomes quite a bit
easier if you have access to water jugs
which you probably do you can do
virtually anything you would use
dumbbells for and then if you get
adjustable dumbbells you know you can do
you can do anything you could do with
dumbbells I don't need to make a list
for you and then and then if you get if
you get some like lifting bands as well
which again you can get a very good set
for a hundred and fifty bucks or if you
want to roll the dice with a cheaper
Amazon bender you can get them for even
less you can do everything you can
you can keep your back in shape so for
for somewhere between zero and two
hundred dollars you're set and you know
if you were never going to go back to a
gym again
then you know you may want to invest
money in a full home gym set up but for
a few weeks or a few months of
quarantine and living in your apartment
you can you can do incredibly productive
training for
somewhere between 0 and 200 bucks
definitely so what like I said keep an
eye out for that article over it's
stronger by science comm we're hoping to
get that information out pretty pretty
soon here we're about to move on from
coronavirus related topics and never
come back
at least that's that's the plan until
we've got some good news but because it
is such an important topic I do want to
make sure that we're super clear kind of
summarizing what we've gone over here so
when it comes to the corona virus you
know first and foremost if you're
listening to this or if you're not
listening to this we hope you're safe
and healthy and doing well
obviously the news is pretty pretty
bleak these days so we don't want to
contribute any more to that than we have
to but we do sincerely hope that you're
doing well we did talk a little bit
about immune function again there's
nothing you can really do to like ultra
supercharge your immune system but we
talked about some basic health related
behaviors that can play a supportive
role in maintaining proper immune
function you know we talked a little bit
about products going around we don't
have an issue with people who put out
good content about immune function the
immune system and the inner you know the
the interaction with nutrition or
supplementation that is not inherently a
bad thing that's not something that were
upset about but the thing that we're
really talking about is people who are
purposefully exploiting fears and trying
to turn that into profit so don't fall
prey to that a lot of people are out
there doing it it's shameful but you
know yeah that stuff's gross but you
know good normal health supporting
habits you know we talked about managing
training load and stuff like that and is
there anything else you want to add
before we move on there I don't think so
no so everybody take care of yourself oh
one other thing
you know listen to the big health
organizations world health organization
you know your local and national
authorities you know the stuff that
they're telling us to do is not special
washing hands social distancing but but
listen to their guidelines take it
seriously and do your best not only to
keep yourself healthy but keep the
people around you healthy even the
people you don't know so that's
pretty much all we have to say about it
we are completely moving on and in order
to do that we're gonna do a special
segment of good news only good vibes
good news stories and I'm gonna start
that so a cool story I saw the other day
not fitness-related but just good news
in general a person named Eleanor lelou
it's a person who is running for a
council seat in their local municipal
government in France and the unique
thing about this story is that Eleanor
has Down syndrome and so she's running
for public office again it's a council
seat in the local government and she's
running on a platform that's largely
focused on accessibility for people who
are visually impaired hearing impaired
and also people who have a variety of
physical or intellectual disabilities so
it's just it's a really nice story
raises a lot of really positive
awareness advocates for accessibility
for a lot of people who really struggle
with accessibility in certain public
places and it helps with reducing some
stigmas you know something I've talked
about a little bit on the podcast in the
past is working with Special Olympics
once again I'm gonna encourage anyone
listening if you ever have the
opportunity it's a really fantastic
organization to get involved with you're
gonna meet a ton of really awesome
people you are going to have a fantastic
time so if that opportunity ever
presents itself I very very much
recommend it but really good story and
fingers crossed hoping that Eleanor wins
the election and secures that seat that
would be awesome
so mine is a little bit less personal to
me but I also thought it was very cool
so dr. Seuss Theodore gazelle that's how
I've always pronounced his name that's
probably wrong that's par for the course
at this point it's kind of our brand
yes mispronouncing names yeah that's a
pillar isola so dr. Seuss unfortunately
passed away in 1991 but he had some some
notes and manuscripts lying about I
believe the most recent dr. Seuss book
was published in 2015 and a new one is
scheduled to come out
in September of this year it is called
dr. Seuss's Horse Museum and it is a
book about art so I love dr. Seuss the
first book I ever read was a dr. Seuss
book so not like the first book that
someone read to me but as I was learning
how to read I should remember which one
it is but I do vividly remember the
first book that I could actually make it
all the way through and pronounce all of
the words and my mom was so proud of me
was a dr. Seuss book so I have have very
good vibes very positive associations
with dr. Seuss so it's cool that that a
new book of his is coming out and just
that his legacy is is being carried on a
a lot of good lessons in those books so
man dr. Seuss books have so many good
lessons in them and they're less less
just like preachy than then-current
children's books are I feel like I mean
to an adult the message still like hits
you over the head and the thing was they
may have not been effective like maybe
kids were just too dense to understand
what dr. Seuss was trying to say I like
to believe they weren't but come to
think of it when I was like 6 years old
I didn't know what any of them were
about except that there were pretty
pictures so whatever they could have
been very ineffective as as like a
didactic like moral lesson teaching
strategy for young kids but I feel like
they were more artful than a lot of
children's books are these days I love
dr. Seuss new dr. Seuss book called dr.
Seuss's horse Museum is coming out in
September and to me that feels like good
news yeah I think I mentioned when we
were talking before recording I actually
I think I was in Portland but I'm not
certain but I was just kind of wandering
around I was visiting for a few days and
I saw an art studio and I just popped in
to check out some of the art and it was
a bunch of like dr. Seuss art that was
it wasn't like you know the
it wasn't like The Greatest Hits right
it was like characters that never really
found their way into a story like real
like deep track kind of stuff you know
stuff you've never seen but very much in
his style it was really really cool I
believe that was in Portland that I saw
it but um if someone who lives in
Portland will let me know if I'm correct
I'm sure but some of his art was just
really really cool it was a fun time but
yeah so uh I'm sure that's gonna be a
cool book so if you're interested in
more dr. Seuss content I think this is
something that at this point a lot of
people know but is still somewhat
unknown at least to a fair amount of
people is either at the same time dr.
Seuss was publishing children's books or
before he got into publishing children's
books one of the two
he was a nationally syndicated political
cartoonist so if you're interested in
what dr. Seuss had to say about things
other than the Lorax or the Cat in the
Hat
you can just google dr. Seuss political
cartoons they're pretty good and it is
very interesting because you know
they're they're not children's books
they were I believe aimed at adults but
they're still in the same art style so
if you've only been exposed to dr. Seuss
the children's author it's it's kind of
fun I think just to google dr. Seuss
political cartoons and check them out
very nice all right great you want to
move on to the Q&A segment let's do it
so we're gonna kick it off with a
question for Eric from Bart Bart asks
what is the evidence around nutrition
and injury prevention or recovery
specifically is there any research on
prolonged cuts and effects on injury
risk Thanks
yeah so there are a couple ways by which
you could argue that cutting might not
be awesome for injury risk you know
could make make a slight increase in
injury risk so one approach logically
looking at it is that potentially if
you're not really managing your training
load effectively
and your tissues aren't really
adequately recovering from the stressors
you're putting on them from training you
could argue that you know if the if the
energy deficiency that you're imposing
you know if you're taking a really big
deficit you know really rapid approach
to your weight loss you could certainly
argue that you're not giving the tissues
an adequate opportunity to recover
between training sessions another thing
that we've talked about I don't remember
if we've talked about on the podcast or
in a mass article but we've talked about
the idea that when we are acutely
fatigued we can see a breakdown of our
motor mechanics and higher forces
getting diverted to passive non
contractile tissues so that fatigue
causing form break down causing
unaccustomed loads on tissues that
really aren't used to accommodating
those types of loads and so in those
cases we can see instances where if you
are training really hard in a really big
deficit and inducing a great deal of
fatigue during the session itself you
could potentially run into a scenario
that's likely to increase your chance of
an acute injury so you can largely get
around those two things by properly
managing your training load and recovery
and properly managing your energy
deficits so you know it's we kind of
view it as a binary thing you're either
cutting or you're not but really you
know there's a huge spectrum of exactly
how large is that energy deficit you
know if you're pushing it really really
hard there's a good chance that you
could increase the likelihood of injury
to some extent but but you know managing
your training load properly managing
your fatigue managing your overall
energy deficit should set you up you
know it's not like Oh once you're in a
deficit you're getting hurt no matter
what you know that that's not at all the
case but you do want to keep those
things in mind if you're trying to train
hard through you know a pretty sizable
energy deficit there are some more
general guidelines about basically if
you're if you're concerned about injury
prevention or recovering from injury
there's some general guidelines about
how you should eat and these were
published in 2009
tene by close and colleagues and so the
the main highlights that they talk about
in this paper first of all making sure
you have sufficient energy intake and so
that kind of goes along with what I was
saying about making sure yeah you can be
an energy deficit to some extent but the
question is how large a deficit the
larger it is the more likely we're gonna
run into issues with either injury
occurrence or recovery from previous
injury number two making sure you have
sufficient protein and I'm sure if
you're listening to this podcast we no
longer have to work hard to convince you
to eat a lot of protein that that's kind
of part of what you sign up for I hope
so
another thing some of the specific
nutrients they point out making sure you
have sufficient intake of vitamin C
vitamin D copper omega-3 fatty acids and
calcium that's just a handful of the
really key ones that they highlight in
the paper now it's really really
important to stress this if someone says
like hey want to be healthy
don't be deficient in vitamin C that
does not mean you know 10,000 milligrams
a day and now you're superhuman all
they're saying is don't have
deficiencies once you have adequate
amounts you're good so they do mention a
few potential supplements that could
have utility for people who are again
really focused in on either prevention
or recovery from previous injury the
supplements that they that they talk
about mostly include creatine gelatin or
collagen vitamin D fish oil and just a
basic multivitamin mineral supplement so
again the idea with the vitamin D in the
the vitamin and mineral supplements is
just making sure that you don't have an
underlying deficiency again same thing
with fish oil I mentioned omega-3 fatty
acids if you do happen to have low
dietary intake of omega-3s a fish oil
supplement is a fantastic idea
creatine pretty self-explanatory has
positive effects on a variety of soft
tissues including muscle and tendon and
then gelatin and collagen if you're a
mass reader we've covered some previous
research on gelatin and collagen
generally speaking seems to have
either a neutral to positive effect on
the recovery of connective tissues
following stressors induced by exercise
so you know I I'm not ready to call
gelatin or collagen a lifesaver yet but
there is good evidence that they again
have a neutral to positive effect when
it comes to helping those soft tissues
you know if you're worried about the
recovery of you know tendons and
ligaments stuff like that after exercise
bone as well gelatin and collagen might
be helpful in that regard so those are
kind of the basic things to focus on if
you are trying to really fine-tune your
nutrition and injury or recovery are at
the forefront of your mind all right
question for Gregg this one is from
Edward Longshanks the question is should
lifters with long limbs trained
differently compared to someone who's
kind of more normally proportioned their
words not mine okay some of the more
typical proportions does this advice
change if the focus is strength versus
hypertrophy yeah so just in general let
me note on the front end that neither of
us are particularly tall so I'm about
six three Erik's about six one but not
like super tall by any means and I think
we're fair I think we're both fairly
normally proportioned I have slightly
short arms and slightly long legs but
both within like one standard deviation
of average proportions and I think the
same applies to you as well so I'm not
necessarily speaking from personal
experience here however my wife is my
primary training partner she is fairly
tall and has pretty long limbs actually
super long limbs and I have a fair
amount of experience training athletes
and a lot of them were football players
but a fair amount of them were
basketball players so they were quite
tall and quite gangly and what I will
note is a lot of the things I'm about to
say they're gonna be phrased
in a way that therefore people with
relatively long limbs but a lot of those
people will also just be people who are
tall in general one thing to note about
human body proportions this is kind of a
fun fact I think is that there is a
positive association between being tall
and having long limbs relative to total
body height the reason for that is so if
you compare adult proportions to baby
proportions limbs are a larger total
percentage of body height for adults
than they are for babies babies have
relatively long torsos and short little
limbs and then when you're growing bones
elongate at growth plates and the growth
plates of your long bones so you know
the bones of your arms the bones of your
legs those growth plates are are more
active and produce a larger or a greater
increase in length in those long bones
than the growth plates of your vertebra
do so during childhood and adolescence
as you are growing and getting taller
you have a larger proportional increase
in in length of the bones of your arms
and legs than you do the length of the
bones of your torso
and so people who wind up tall generally
that trend is going to continue so
someone who's 6 foot 5 on average is
certainly going to have longer arms and
legs than someone who's 5 foot 10 or
whatever but also their arms and legs
will probably be longer relative to
their body height than someone who is
shorter or more normal-sized so
everything I'm about to say it doesn't
necessarily matter how tall you are just
you know for people who have long limbs
relative to body height but that will on
average tend to be taller people so just
wanted to start with that fun little
fact about human development so for
starters talking about modifying
exercises in general so for squats if
you're someone who's relatively tall you
may want to play around with wider
stance squats so if you're someone
tall someone who has long legs that's
going that's going to mean that's gonna
mean one of two things either to hit
depth you have to lean further forward
or to hit depth you need more forward
knee travel for any given stance with an
amount of hip abduction and so if you
can squat with a wider stance and you
can get your knees out further that
effectively makes your your thighs
shorter in the sagittal plane and so
that means you don't need quite as much
for of a knee travel or quite as much
forward lean to squat to depth so it's
gonna make your your squat a little bit
more efficient and it means generally
that you don't have to lean quite as far
forward to be able to hit depth so it's
worth playing around with a wider stance
if that isn't doable for you if you
can't if you just can't do a wider
stance because your hips aren't built
that way then there's no shame in just
using a shorter range of motion still
continue to squat if you you know if if
to hit depth that requires a ton of
forward lean and maybe some spinal
flexion in the process you'll be
perfectly fine just cutting your squats
a little bit above parallel you know
that's obviously not legal for
powerlifting but just for you know
general training purposes that is just
fine so that's from a strength
perspective from a hypertrophy
perspective that may mean that squats
aren't necessarily the best hypertrophy
exercise for you because you won't be
able to train your quads through that
long range of motion so if any of that
applies to you you can't squat to depth
a wide stance squat isn't really
amenable to you then you know doing
stuff like leg press or hack squats or
anything that allows you to train your
quads through a longer range of motion
might then be more feasible and a better
exercise for quad hypertrophy for
deadlifts one of the things I have
generally found which may not
necessarily be intuitive if you watch
strength sports is that I have found
that for taller people
again much like the wide stance squats
if their hips allow it
sumo deadlifts tend to tend to work
quite well so the reason I gave that
caveat is for power lifters you tend to
see sumo deadlifts disproportionately in
the lower weight classes and you tend to
see conventional deadlifts
disproportionately in the higher weight
classes and then if you look at like
world Strongest Man competitors
virtually all of them well not virtually
all of them deadlift conventional the
reason you see that with strongman is
because you have to deadlift
conventional and strongman strongman has
weird rules and rules that change event
to event and competition to competition
but one of the things that's that's a
constant is that sumo deadlifts aren't
allowed so we don't know how many Pro
strongmen would be better sumo deadlift
errs if that was allowed a and then B
with power lifters one of the things
that I don't have data to support but
I've just seen from coaching a lot of
people is that folks who are more gangly
like who have longer arms and legs tend
to do better with sumo deadlifts on
average but you aren't necessarily going
to see them as super successful like 275
or super heavy weight power lifters
because you know if you're 6 3 and 1/2
super arm long super long arms and legs
unless you're Brad Gillingham who's a
freak you're probably not gonna be an
incredibly successful power lifter on
the international stage so 1 the most
successful super heavies tend to not be
incredibly tall and 2 they tend to be
they tend to have proportions more
similar to shorter people that are more
amenable to squatting and benching and
so one of the things you see when you
actually look at trends and the data is
that at least in the IPF deadlift
numbers increase up to either the 93 or
the 105 kilo class and then they're
pretty much flat from their 120s and
super heavies don't tend to deadlift
much more than the 93 s and 105 so you
tend to see in the higher weight classes
people succeeding more if they have an
archetypal bench and squat build which
means kind of shorter limbs than average
and then they struggle a little bit more
in the deadlift
and maybe those folks do a little bit
better with the conventional deadlift
than the sumo but I find that a lot of
tall people and just people with with
disproportionately long limbs do tend to
do better with the sumo deadlift and
then again just like I said for the
squat if your hips just don't allow for
sumo if that if that just doesn't work
with you not legal for powerlifting but
there is absolutely no shame in training
your deadlift through a shorter range of
motion or if it's a little bit more
comfortable to get down to the bar with
more forward knee travel
there's also perfectly fine to do trap
our deadlifts so those would be two
things that I would generally recommend
in terms of hypertrophy modifications
for training the posterior chain for
someone with relatively long limbs I
don't really think you need any just
because both for for pulling movements
and for squatting movements you're
probably gonna have more forward lean on
average and your your lifts are going to
wind up looking more hip dominant than
the typical person anyways so if you're
training heavy compound lower body
exercises your glutes and hamstrings an
entire posterior chain are probably
getting plenty of work already so you
know if you're interested in more glued
or hamstring growth anything that one
would ever recommend for glute and
hamstring growth would apply to you but
in terms of how one would need to modify
just normal day to day training for
those purposes I don't necessarily think
you're gonna need to on average and then
last thing is bench so if you're someone
who struggles with bench because you
have really long arms it's tough there's
there's not really too much you can say
about that
range of motions gonna be longer that's
gonna make the lift more challenging
it might inherently make it a little bit
more beneficial for hypertrophy so one
of the things we talked about on the
podcast previously and that we had a an
article and stronger by science about is
how if someone has a very very efficient
bench set up bench may essentially turn
into a partial range motion exercise
which you know is great for putting up
big numbers on the platform but may not
necessarily be ideal for hypertrophy if
you're someone who has really long arms
relative to body height and especially
if you're tall and just have really long
arms in an absolute sense you don't need
to worry about that so like bench is
gonna be fantastic as a hypertrophy
exercise if you're trying to optimize
things for strength really the same
things that I would recommend to
everyone would apply to you so you know
see if you're comfortable with the
maximum legal width grip so 81
centimeters so pointer fingers on the
little grip rings try to work on your
arch especially if you want to be a
competitive bench or if you have really
long arms technique is gonna be really
really important to you so trying to
minimize range of motion is a good idea
for everyone trying to optimize weight
that they can lift on the platform that
is going to be doubly or triple e true
for you so working on your arch working
on really dialing in your technique
trying to get comfortable with a maximum
legal width grip you'll probably still
be at some degree of disadvantage just
because you have really long arms but
those things will to the greatest degree
possible help narrow the playing field
and are probably going to be more
important for you than they would be for
most people and like i'd like i
mentioned for both squats and deadlifts
if you have really really long arms and
you also have not the biggest ribcage
even bench may not be the perfect
exercise for you so if you're if you're
benching and bringing the bar to your
chest for most people most of the time
that is a perfectly safe
range of motion to go through but if
you're someone with arms that are so
long that by the time the bar reaches
your chest your elbows are like a foot
and a half behind your spine that's
probably gonna require I don't want to
say probably that very well could
require more shoulder flexion or
shoulder extension that would then would
necessarily be advisable under heavy
load so I wouldn't say go out and make
you know any any rash changes right now
but if if you have super long arms
and you find that binge isn't super
comfortable for your shoulders again
this isn't legal for powerlifting but
just like bench press can be a partial
range of motion exercise for some people
it may be a greater than maximum range
of motion exercise for you and in that
case partials would be just fine so
something like benching to a one board
or if you have super long arms maybe a
two board that would be good
something like floor press even though
that would probably still be a partial
range range of motion exercise floor
press would be fine you know benching
partials depends with pin set maybe two
or three inches off of your chest if you
find that that's a little bit more
comfortable for your shoulders that
would be a good exercise modification to
make and much like I said for for
deadlifts since you have long arms if
you're benching you don't need to worry
about range of motion as far as
hypertrophy is concerned so bench in and
of itself would probably be a great
hypertrophy exercise for your pecs and
and really for anyone to a lesser degree
your triceps so so I don't necessarily
think you would need to change your
approach to PEC growth if you have
particularly long arms just kind of from
an aesthetic perspective and again no
judgement but if you have long limbs you
need more total muscle to look big and
impressive so just in a general sense
I'd probably recommend more direct arm
work anyways you know if you have super
long arm
you may need 17-inch arms to look the
same as 15-inch arms on someone else so
just just in general doing more arm
training is probably a smart thing to do
if you're someone who trains for
aesthetics but uh oh yeah those are
those are my general thoughts in general
I wouldn't necessarily make huge changes
right off the bat but but just to recap
a little bit for squats they may not
agree with your hips but it's worth at
least playing around with a wider stance
squat if that is comfortable for you
that will probably be the way to go
every so I like I said I've trained a
fair amount of basketball players and a
few volleyball players who were quite
tall and had long legs everyone who
tried the wide stance squat if their
hips allowed wide stance squats they
would come back to me immediately and
say like holy [ __ ] my complete like my
total outlook on squats has changed so
you may not have hips that allow that
but if your hips do allow that play
around with a wider stance play around
with with with more hip abduction so
getting your knees out further if that
feels good that's probably gonna help
squats a lot but again if that doesn't
work no shame in partial range of motion
and kind of do leg press hack squats
something that allows you to train your
quads through a slightly longer range of
motion for a hypertrophy perspective for
posterior chain stuff or for PEC stuff
don't necessarily need to do anything
crazy for hypertrophy for deadlifts at
least give sumo a shot if sumo doesn't
feel good conventional doesn't feel good
just do trap our trap bars find partials
are also fine and then again for bench
you very well may need to to do partial
range of motion as well if you're
someone who wants to compete in
powerlifting maximum legal with at least
give it a shot really play around with
your been charged try to make it as big
as possible and just as a general bro
tip do more arm work your arms probably
need to get pretty big a quick technical
note gangly that is the preferred
medical term right I know that came up a
few times we try to stay away from the
jargon but but that bad and that is the
medical term I believe correct or
daddy longlegs esque yes that's another
one perfect I think that's derived from
from Vlad probably so I mean it's either
Greek or Latin roots with all of these
medical terms who can say yeah all right
so we have two protein questions for
Erik coming up next the first is from
Hall BC they asked
there are huge discrepancies with
protein guidelines official nutrition
organizations often recommend around
0.23 6 grams per pound which is
obviously too low if your goal is to
build muscle and strength however I hear
some bodybuilders eating 4 or 500 grams
per day where is the sweet spot from
your personal experience and secondly
can you overdo protein intake the second
question here is from Hassan Hassan asks
for my total daily protein intake should
I only count proteins from animals and
dairy sources 100 grams of oats has
about 12 grams of protein but should I
count that as say 6 grams because of the
protein quality what about bread peas
nuts seeds etc so should you count
animal sources of protein the same as
plant sources of protein in terms of
meeting total daily protein targets yeah
let's talk total amount first and then
we'll talk about you know complete
versus incomplete proteins so we just
had a paper come out when I say we I
mean Brandon Roberts Eric Helms me and
Peter Fitch and we just had a paper come
out called nutritional recommendations
for physique athletes and you know it's
it's oriented toward physique athletes
but it's basically anyone with physique
related goals in mind you know you don't
have to take every every guideline to
the extreme and take everything to the
stage you could still implement this
stuff and we talked you know between us
we talked about the different protein
guidelines you see out there what the
what the what the evidence tells us in
terms of what protein values seem to
really get the job done and what we what
we shared in the paper is basically that
there's a range of a pretty broad range
where it looks like if you're with
in that range you've got enough you know
you've got enough protein to feel good
about and you can kind of rest assured
that you've that you're maximizing what
you're doing in the gym you're eating
enough protein to support your physique
goals and from our perspective that
range was one point six to two point
seven grams per kilogram per day of
protein however we also noted that
there's really not much evidence to
suggest that high protein high protein
intake is going to negatively impact
things so we felt you might as well skew
yourself a little toward the top end of
that range so what we what we generally
recommend is one point eight to two
point seven grams per kilograms per day
for most people finding yourself
somewhere in that range you're gonna
have more than enough you know I've seen
people in the past recommend one point
six to two point two we just kind of
shifted that upward a little bit based
on the evidence and based on you know
what's the downside of undershooting it
versus what is the theoretical downside
of overshooting it and based on illicit
funding from big big protein
manufacturers right no no those are
those are very good people that fought
did that that's sarcasm okay so it's
sarcasm they're terrible people yeah
awful awful people so that's that's the
the kind of guideline that we put out
there but we also mentioned you know the
theoretical downside of undershooting
your protein is you left some gains on
the table that sucks you know that
that's why we're looking over these
details is because we don't want to
leave gains on the table the theoretical
downsides of going a little too high
with protein are pretty negligible the
only thing we mentioned is you know some
people want to go above that 2.7 grams
per kilogram per day and in some cases
that can help if you're trying to
mitigate hunger really hedge your bets
if you're like pretty lean and cutting
hard and you really want to make sure
you retain every ounce of muscle maybe
you want to skew even higher than 2.7
the only time it really becomes
problematic you know you could go up to
3.5 grams per kilogram per day and still
feel pretty good about it the only issue
is at a certain point especially if
you're dieting
could run into a situation where you're
eating so much protein that you're
displacing your fats and your carbs in
the diet so in order for you to you know
keep your caloric intake in the proper
range you're eating so much protein that
you're unable to get sufficient amounts
of fat or carbohydrate that's one
potential downside another potential
downside of going too high with the
protein is the other end of the spectrum
maybe you're trying to bulk up and
you're noticing like I just cannot eat
this many calories because a lot of
times people with high-protein diets
they tend to find that it can be very
satiating and that they feel very full
on a high protein diet and so some of
Jose Antonio's papers where they put
people on really high protein intakes
like as high as like four point I think
like four point four grams per kilogram
I think that was the highest the main
thing that they'll note in those studies
is like a little side effect is like
some people were just like I'm way too
full I feel gross all the time you know
but so there are some potential
downsides but it's usually not until you
get into they're really high really high
intake so generally speaking one point
eight to two point seven you can feel
really confident knowing that you're not
leaving gains on the table and you're
probably not gonna run into any issues
certainly no health related issues
within that range assuming that you're
an otherwise healthy person just those
little considerations of you know
managing the appetite and making sure
you're getting enough fat and
carbohydrate as well now I have intended
to see practically speaking that when
you see the really high protein intakes
like the question I think mentioned like
400 500 grams per day a lot of times you
see that in the bodybuilding world and
particularly in the not natural
bodybuilding world where there are some
drugs at play
dude that was that was the stock
recommendation of a [ __ ] what was the
name of that forum dante trudells people
intense muscle I think that I think
that's what it was I there for like four
months at one point but dude that was
that was the the DC recommendation 500
grams a day doesn't matter how big you
are
it's
magic number everyone should eat 500
grams of protein per day dude I did that
for like four or five months ho buddy
so one I gained a ton of weight because
I was in college at the time I had no
income whatsoever
I was I was destitute Lee poor yeah I
was trying to kind of guesstimate 500
grams of protein per day from food from
the school cafeteria and so I would get
as much like lunch meat
turkey and ham as they would give me but
you know there's a limit to that and
then I had a I had a good relationship
with several of the people working in
the cafeteria and they would just load
me up but otherwise they would give me
like four or five slices of turkey and
ham and then send me on my merry way and
say you know try to get your hundred and
seventy grams of protein and you're
trying to get in at this meal from some
other source and then really the next
best bet in the cafeteria was skim milk
yeah so I would drink an enormous amount
of skim milk but skim milk still has
about one gram of carbs per gram of
protein so yeah it's usually more it's
usually like twelve carbs and a protein
I think something like that I don't know
it still has a fair amount of carbs in
it so that that was my next best route
but it would still guarantee like
minimum five six hundred grams of carbs
per day and you know there you can one
can only drink a finite amount of skim
milk so then anything else that I would
get in the food lines you know would
have a fair amount of fat in it because
you know it's it's a cheap school
cafeteria like it is what it is
so dude I was getting in 500 grams of
protein a day but I was conservatively
eating dude if I said 4,000 I guarantee
you that undershoot said it was probably
five six thousand calories a day
yeah higher than four it was a [ __ ] show
um all of which is to say I don't think
someone needs to go that high in and if
you do go that high do it when you have
a stable income and you can buy protein
powder and [ __ ] egg whites and lean
don't try to eat 500 grams of protein
per day in a school cafeteria I I did
that I made that mistake so you don't
have to it was not it was not a good
time on any level whatsoever so our
dining hall back in the day there were a
lot of options it was like all you could
eat like omelets and eggs and chicken
breasts like you could have made it work
depending on your dining all situated
that's because you went to Ohio State I
did it was a lovely place I went to a
tiny Christian school in the middle of
nowhere are so I don't want to sound
like I'm talking bad about the people
who worked in the cafeteria they were
all lovely they were fantastic yeah but
Aramark not my favorite company they're
not good I don't know what that company
is they were they were the people who
like ran the school cafeteria like oh I
had a contract with them dude [ __ ]
Aramark it was it was the worst every
everything about I'm not gonna go on an
arrow mark rant right now I'm sure I
will at some point I had forgotten how
much I hated arrow mark I hadn't thought
about that goddamn company for probably
like five years but dude [ __ ] Aramark
they're the worst fair enough
so usually when you see those in tanks
like 405 it's usually not necessarily in
the natural sign of bodybuilding and I
think I think a lot of people are under
the impression like because you're on
anabolics you're having all this
additional protein synthesis and like
you got to feed into that with all the
raw materials required I'm extremely
skeptical that it would move your
protein needs that much I've also heard
people argue the opposite that like oh
you're on a anabolics you don't even
need that much protein because like the
drugs will do it I don't think that
really makes a lot of sense to me either
I think probably and I'm really curious
I haven't looked into it super closely I
would think maybe if anything you would
just shift your protein needs a little
bit higher on drugs a little of what
what do you think I don't know yeah be
night I probably wouldn't change a much
you know I like it's like you're either
initiate the synthesis you're not I
can't imagine but I think if I had to
guess I think that's probably the logic
behind a lot of it it's like I'm on
drugs I need to build proteins better
have some amino acids around but you're
not building that much more like like
that's pretty crazy but but anyway I
would say regardless of your situation
1.8 to 2.7 is probably a very safe range
for most in terms of making sure you're
getting enough and not displacing other
important nutrients regarding protein
quality incomplete proteins if you're in
that range 1.8 to 2.7 you're not just
getting enough but you're probably
getting a little bit more than enough
like that's again the range is supposed
to be like a safe range where you feel
really good about your intake if you're
eating a mixture of complete and
incomplete proteins you you're probably
getting all the essential amino acids
you need you're probably getting all the
leucine per meal that you need and it's
probably not not critical to get that
you know get out the magnifying glass
and start sorting through your protein
sources and saying well that's a good
source and that's about 70 percent of a
good source and that's about 45 percent
of a good source you're probably fine if
you're up in that range I would say this
though if you are a hundred percent
vegan or if you eat very very minimal
animal products and the overwhelming
majority of your proteins do come from
non animal sources in that in that
circumstance I would recommend probably
bumping your total protein total protein
intake up a little bit just to
accommodate for the fact that all of the
protein sources are a little bit lower
in quality you know there's a great
article on this on the site about
plant-based protein sources it's
stronger by science basically how to
arrange your diet if you're on a
plant-based diet and not consuming
animal products to a large degree and
that's the same recommendation is just
skew yourself a little bit toward the
higher end of the recommendations so
maybe instead of just coming in at 1.8
you say I'm gonna shoot a little higher
I'm gonna get up in the tuple
22.4 2.7 range just to account for the
fact that these are all incomplete
sources so I don't think it's it's worth
stressing over the exact amino acid
profiles and and getting super super you
know into the weeds on that getting
really into the details but I would say
just move yourself a little bit up
toward the higher end of that spectrum
just to be safe and you should be
totally fine alright question for Gregg
here and this question is from Charlie
based on the recent article about
strength and range of motion in the
benchpress do you think there is enough
evidence to justify modifying training
for competitive power lifters for
example incorporating some bench
pressing with a flatter arch and
narrower grip for some portion of
training so basically just curious if
you think that people should basically
have some dedicated training with a
longer range of motion in their bench
pressing yeah I would say so
and I would also say just kind of like
based on how this question is phrased do
you think there's enough evidence to
justify modifying training
I wouldn't even necessarily view it as a
modification mostly because I thought
before we get into it you might tell us
what that article was about strength and
range of motion in the bench press yeah
so essentially there was a study that
came out which compared strength gains
for people benching through a full range
of motion through a two-thirds range of
motion so like the top two thirds of the
range of motion and a one-third range of
motion so just like the top third of the
range of motion and it was looking at
strength gains through all three of
those range of motions so you know the
group that that trained through a full
range of motion would have their full
range of motion
two-thirds range range of motion and
one-third range of motion one RMS
tested pre and post-training same thing
for all three groups and what that study
found overall is that the full range of
motion group had the largest strength
gains through not just a full range of
motion but also through a partial
through both partial ranges of motion as
well so the full range of motion group
also gained the most strength through a
two-thirds range of motion and also
gained the most strength through a
one-third range motion as well so it it
pretty much cleaned house for all of the
results and so in in my I don't want to
call it analysis that makes it sound way
too stilted informal in my write-up of
that study one of the things I
speculated is that the subjects weren't
super super well trained so they had
some prior training experience but you
know they weren't called bingeing like
405 or anything like that
and so I speculated that they didn't
assess hypertrophy in that study but
it's pretty likely that the group
training through the longest range of
motion also had the most muscle growth
both in terms of packs and triceps and
probably front delts as well and so that
that was probably driving the results
there and so I mean like my answer to
this question wouldn't just rely on that
one study so we have pretty good
evidence just generally that you don't
necessarily need to Train through a
maximal range of motion like the longest
possible range of motion to maximize
muscle growth but if you if you restrict
range of motion too much it probably
will be counterproductive for muscle
growth so you know just just to put
numbers on this if you have a hundred
and forty degrees of usable range of
motion of elbow flexion say you probably
don't necessarily need to do curls
through that entire hundred and forty
degree range of motion like one hundred
and twenty very well maybe fine but if
you're only going through say seventy
degrees that's probably insufficient and
so the thing with benchpress is is like
I talked about before bench pressing for
people with really really long arms if
you don't have really really long arms a
full range of motion bench press is
already arguably a partial range of
motion exercise at least for a fair
amount of the prime movers
so it may be close to a full range of
motion for the pecs but probably not
quite so in terms of shoulder horizontal
adduction like if you were just doing
flies your elbows could probably get a
little bit further below your shoulders
doing flies than they would if you were
doing bench press it's certainly not a
full range of motion for your triceps
unless you're benching with a super
close grip so at the bottom of like a
normal competition bench press
you're nowhere near close to maximal
elbow flexion and possibly the same
thing for front delts so most people do
have a pretty fair amount of shoulder
extension in the bench press so it so it
is probably somewhere pretty close to
full range of motion for the front delts
but not completely full range of motion
so anyways a competition bench press
especially if it's a wide grip and a big
arch is arguably a partial range of
motion exercise in the first place and
so the the authors of the particular
study I wrote about in like my personal
feelings on the subject as well are that
maybe it's beneficial to do some some
portion of your bench press training
through a longer range of motion than
you would typically get from a you know
traditional competitive bench setup with
a maximum legal grip with and a bunch of
arch etc and so going back to Charlie's
question he asked do you think there's
enough evidence to justify modifying
trainer training for competitive power
lifters and I would argue that it
wouldn't necessarily be a modification
most of the time because if you look at
it most successful lifters bench press
programs you generally see close curb
bench in there as well like that's that
is a very very common auxilary or
supplemental lift for the bench press
like I think most people do some Close
Grip training or like they do some
dumbbell bench and generally dumbbell
bench is going to have a longer range of
motion than barbell bench
I talked about how it's probably fairly
close to full range of motion for the
pecs but pretty far off it for the
triceps most lifters do some sort of
dedicated tricep training as well so I
wouldn't necessarily argue that this
would be a large modification but what I
would say is that if all of the
benchpress training you do is just with
your competition set up especially if
you have a very efficient competition
set up and you have reasonably short
arms or at least not super long arms
then it probably would be worth doing
something with a longer range of motion
in your program somewhere so that could
be you know you go through your full
competition setup but you just do a
close grip that's necessarily going to
increase range of motion or you know you
could just do some of your benching but
the smaller arch if you're someone who
has a really big arch something I
personally really enjoy both because it
increases range of motion and it
increases the range of motion where the
lift is challenging is benching with
feet up so you're minimizing leg Drive
you're making it harder at the bottom of
the lift which is you know a probably
where stress to the musculature is going
to be most beneficial for I perch fee in
the first place and to where it's most
important to be able to generate force
and power to get that bar moving off of
your chest so I really love feed up
bench and you just simply can't get as
big of an arch when you're doing that so
I think I think all of those exercises
are great another one which I've talked
about on the podcast before which I
absolutely love is a low incline bench
that's going to be a fairly similar
motor pattern but it's also going to
have a longer range of motion because
know even with a slight incline just
1520 degrees at that point you're
touching the bar to your chest you're
not touching it you know at or below
your sternum so like range of motion is
gonna have to be longer another thing
that I really really like is benching
with a cambered bar or a McDonald bar
named after Mike McDonald who in my
opinion is probably the most successful
at least male bench presser ever on the
female side of things it's it's hard to
argue against
Jennifer Thompson but man might think
Donald at one point if my memory is
correct held the all-time world record
in the bench press in four different
weight classes which which is wild and
so he did a lot of bench with a with a
bar that had like a three or four inch
chamber that large of a chamber might be
overkill for a lot of people but if
there is like a 3/4 inch chamber barge
or gym and you you take that to a one
board so it's extending the range of
motion by about two inches I think
that's an awesome supplemental lift for
the bench press but yeah for for people
who especially have a really really good
competition bench setup where you've
minimized range of motion you have a
great arch you have a wide grip I do
think that there's considerable benefit
to doing some of your bench training
with some sort of variation that allows
for a longer range of motion like I said
I don't necessarily view that as a
modification for most people because
most people who do have that hyper
efficient bench setup are already doing
something that trains their bench
through a longer range of motion but if
you know if you just discovered the
magic of a hyper efficient bench setup
and you're like this is the bee's knees
I can you know I can bench seventy more
pounds doing this I'm never benching any
other way again it's worth rethinking
that and maybe taking some weight off
the bar and doing some sort of bench
variation that that does take you
through a longer range of motion may not
necessarily add weight to your max say
next week or next month but it will
probably be beneficial for muscle growth
which will help you bench more you know
over a moderate to longer period of time
good stuff all right next question we
have for Eric is from Jordan Apple Bach
I believe so Jordan asks question for
Eric regarding air-quote fat burners
close air-quote so currently I'm taking
a stimulant free fat burner and multiple
ingredients garcinia cambogia extract
coffee bean extract CLA siedel L
carnitine
and green tea leaf extract and I feel
like it helps me curb my appetite
however I write in because I'm unsure if
I've simply placebo it myself or if it's
actually helping is there anything in
the above ingredients that actually does
anything or am I just wasting my money
yeah so when it comes to those
ingredients listed I really haven't seen
any super compelling evidence to suggest
that they are like effective enough to
really care about I generally don't push
any kind of fat burner supplement either
for the purpose of increasing energy
expenditure or reducing hunger so if
you've read the metabolic adaptation
manual on the website
I do talk a little bit a little bit
about supplements you actually made me
add that part which was good because I
refer back to it all the time but there
are there are a number of supplements
that people suggest will increase their
metabolic rate there therefore you know
increased fat burning and help them get
leader some of the ones that come up a
lot are ephedrine Pisa nephron also
known as bitter orange yohimbine
caffeine nicotine and capsaicin and in
that metabolic adaptation manual I walk
through a couple of the main
shortcomings for each of those so for
example ephedrine is banned in many
countries and you know there's been a
lot of adverse events reported for it so
you know for me that kind of takes it
off my list ephedra is banned in the US
right as far as I'm aware I think it's
so so so purified ephedrine is I believe
you can get a fed rub correct yeah but
not just straight ephedrine yeah yeah so
ephedrine itself there there have been a
number of adverse events reported and so
not not on my list of go-to supplements
that's for sure
piece of Efrain is basically yeah
oversimplified but it's basically a less
potent less effective version of
ephedrine its side effects don't seem to
be as potent but neither do its effects
that you actually want
so if you took enough of it that it did
actually behave like a Fed Rijn very
well maybe just as potentially
problematic I mean I have no idea but
for me it's just like it's just on the
list of no thanks you know it's either
not gonna work or you can try to push it
into ranges that go beyond water studied
correct
yeah-yo hid bean yohimbine actually can
work if you're gonna do like fasted
cardio and use it to support your fasted
cardio the problem is I usually don't
recommend fasted cardio to people so it
does seem like you you really want to
use it for that particular purpose if
you really want to maximize its benefits
I believe it's also on the water band
list yeah it might be if for me the
reason I'm not even certain about that
is because first of all it interacts
with a lot of drugs it has major quality
control issues when it comes to the
dosing and products but most importantly
it's known to cause like from what I for
what I can tell like pretty notable
anxiety symptoms a lot of people I saw
you smiling and that did not go the
direction I thought it would okay yeah
it's also supposed to increase erections
right is that what you're thinking yeah
yeah I I would not recommend taking it
if you're going to be in public I'll
leave it at that yeah fair enough but
but for me one of the reasons I would
never really feel good about
recommending it is I've heard that the
the anxiety related side effects can be
quite notable depending on the person
yeah and it's just like dude for for a
marginal effect on fat loss why would I
bother yeah I'm the the thing that got
me is like I'm not a very anxious person
I've tried yohimbine before I quite like
it as a stimulant but I like stimulants
but but yeah in terms of the other side
effect it was like being in middle
school all over again to the point that
that it was so annoying that even though
I did enjoy the stimulant properties and
this is before it was banned yeah even
though I did enjoy it as a
stimulant dude it was it wasn't a small
problem it was a big enough problem that
it was just just [ __ ] annoying
so yeah women wouldn't necessarily
recommend it fair enough
nicotine so nicotine I mean I don't know
of any people who consider it a
supplement necessarily but
over-the-counter there's the gums and
the patches and all that and from what I
understand I I think it can help people
just as like a general stimulant can
help with appetite regulation stuff like
that the problem is obviously it's quite
quite addictive now you could have a
very interesting discussion about
whether or not it's bad to be addicted
to nicotine that's not a discussion that
I really have much interest in but but
like you you could make the argument if
I'm just chewing the gum or using the
patches and not you know using
carcinogenic dip or chew or inhaling
combustion products a baby
yeah or using some kind of vaping it's
causing all sorts of scarring in my
lungs that no one can explain but you
know like is the nicotine itself if you
are addicted to it how bad is that per
se you know because there's a lot of
people walking around with caffeine
addictions and we don't go like ooh
that's that's really scary stuff but
generally speaking to me it seems like a
I would never feel comfortable telling
somebody like hey why don't you go get
addicted to nicotine because we want to
you know we want to get your lead yeah
especially if we can get you lean
without it and then finally I do want to
talk about caffeine and capsaicin I'm
gonna talk about them together because I
view them the same way you know they're
both quite accessible in a variety of
foods and also supplements they can both
have modest effects on energy
expenditure or appetite control but you
know the effects just aren't that big
you know like yeah maybe a little boost
and energy expenditure a little bit of
help with appetite regulation but the
boost in energy expenditure is not big
enough to really get excited about and
one of the things about you know the
initial question asked about supplements
that help reduce appetite or hunger
I actually advocate to people that are
trying to lose weight to just get rid of
the idea of hunger avoidance you know a
lot of times we give hunger a lot more
power than it deserves in the weight
loss process we like hide from it at all
costs and thing once the hunger shows up
I'm screwed
in reality I think there is quite a
liberating effect of saying you know
what at a certain point in this diet we
are gonna get hungry and that's okay
because most hunger during a diet is not
like chew your arm off you're so hungry
type hunger it's three or four hours
after a meal when it's almost time for
the next meal you notice oh I'm hungry
again that's normal that's not something
that we necessarily need to avoid or be
afraid of or go all these different
supplementation routes to try to to try
to fix now two things I I will use
sometimes you know like cuz like let's
be honest being hungry is not fun so two
things I have noticed that generally
either reduce my hunger or at the very
least reduce my reduce how much I want
to eat would be using you know really
spicy high capsaicin meals or drinking
green tea and the way I utilize those
strategies of my diet a very pragmatic
practical approach if I eat a really
spicy meal with a bunch of capsaicin and
a bunch of red pepper chili pepper black
pepper I make it really spicy you do
notice that the thermogenic effects are
obvious you start sweating as you eat it
but I have noticed that my desire to eat
things after that meal is just kind of
naturally suppressed from that it could
be due the flavor profile could be due
to the actual you know some
physiological component to me doesn't
really matter I just know that I'm less
likely to eat or be inclined to snack on
things after that meal another thing I
do with green tea and by the way there's
research to support both of these either
capsaicin or green tea in terms of
reducing hunger later or reducing desire
to eat later what I've noticed with
green tea again there's research to
indicate there is some physiology
happening but with the green
it's it's really obvious stuff but like
if I have coffee I don't know if I've
talked about this on the podcast before
but like if I have coffee
I want a pastry or some fruit or
anything sweet Coffee goes with a
million foods that are all delicious if
I have green tea in my opinion it goes
with zero things I don't want anything
with green tea and I like green tea but
it does not pair well with any food in
my opinion so a lot of times when I'm
prepping if I do feel like I want to
give myself a little crutch in terms of
hunger avoidance I'll just have some
green tea and you know honestly the
flavour alone is enough for me to say
like I'm not really gonna eat anymore
but but like I said there are some
studies where they give people green tea
or high doses of capsaicin or some other
capsaicinoids and later you know a few
hours later they're less inclined to eat
more so I don't really recommend any
special supplement either for fat loss
or for managing appetite I know there
are a couple out there but I generally
don't like to go down and say oh what if
we try nine different herbal extracts
and hopefully we won't get hungry later
tonight what I prefer as a much more
sustainable approach is generally
becoming comfortable with hunger but if
I ever do feel like I need to lean on a
crutch like that I'll just do a really
spicy meal with a lot of capsaicin
content or I will go with with green tea
either after a meal or between meals and
I do have a lot of clients who suggest
that those have been really helpful
strategies for them as well one thing to
note with capsaicin if you abruptly
dramatically increase your capsaicin
intake it's gonna be spicy your mouth
might not like that this is the
hard-hitting content you come here for
but know that the real part you can run
due to some GI discomfort if you like
really dramatically increase your intake
of spicy foods if you build your way up
to it it's a little bit less notable but
don't just like go nuts and the spice
covered and just throw red pepper on
everything you might run into some GI
discomfort down the line so keep an eye
out for it make sense okay do you want
to do another one who do you want to go
to to play us out let's call it there
all right yeah we don't want Lindsay to
get mad she gets mad if we go over to
ours then we get in trouble correct okay
so to play us out now Greg we've got we
got two things here we've got risotto
and we're only doing the first we're
doing risotto
okay let's go with that all right what
do you want me to say I don't know what
the hell you're gonna talk about it's
risotto I don't even know what risotto
is I assume it's pasta it's not what so
let me educate you about risotto so I
don't know I guess technically you could
make risotto with with like orzo like
really small pasta but risotto is
traditionally a rice dish it's it's
absolutely fantastic and what I want to
say about it is if you're one cooped up
inside for whatever reason including
reasons that we're no longer going to
talk about on this podcast and you want
to learn how to make a fun little dish
that will impress people will not being
all that difficult or you know if you're
just trying to eat macro friendly food
and you want something that is going to
be macro friendly while also feeling and
tasting quite indulgent risotto is a
really really good option so risotto is
essentially a creamy rice dish that is
creamy even if you don't necessarily add
anything creamy to it so to start with
you want to get some rice man I should
have googled this beforehand I think
risottos are traditionally made with
short grain rice but I think that's one
of those tradition things that doesn't
matter all that much I've made it with
both long and short grain rice it comes
out fine either way there's also a bit
of debate I've seen about whether or not
you should rinse the rice before you
before you make risotto with it I tend
not to what I have heard is that
depending where you are in the world and
where you're getting your rice from
there there could possibly be a little
bit of like dirt on the outside of it
and it might give a gritty texture to
your rice that has never happened to me
if I don't rinse rice beforehand
typically you would want to rinse
additionally to get some of the starch
off of the outside of it so after you
cook it each of the individual grains is
more distinct that is what most people
prefer for whatever reason when they
make rice I don't care about that in
general and especially for risotto if
it's rice that isn't going to have dirt
on it and it isn't gonna be gritty if I
don't rinse it I like to not rinse it
because the starch on the outside of the
rice helps make a thicker lusher risotto
in my experience so here's how you make
a damn good risotto so first off if it's
if it's going to be kind of like a full
meal in a dish instead of just a rice
dish if you're gonna put meat in it you
would want to start by searing the meat
once other things go in you wouldn't
want the pan to be hot enough to sear
meat anymore so if you're gonna sear
meat or if you're gonna have anything
else in your risotto that you would want
seared you're either gonna need to sear
it first or sear it in another pan and
then add it back in just to cut down on
the dishes I would recommend Sirian at
first so you're gonna sear the meat high
heat I like throwing mushrooms in
risotto I love mushrooms as we
previously talked about I also like to
sear my mushrooms so start by searing
your meat and or mushrooms and or other
things that need to be seared and then
to continue building flavor this isn't a
necessary step but is one that I would
generally recommend you would want to
turn the heat down once you've got sear
on stuff that you want and throw your
alliums in so that would include things
like onions that would be things like
garlic if you want to throw leeks in
that would work shallots alliums
so you throw the alum the alliums in
you'd let them sweat for a couple
minutes let them start breaking down and
releasing their flavors and then
something that I always do because I
heard that it was the right thing to do
even though I doubt it actually matters
is after you've sweated your alliums
you throw the rice in that you're gonna
cook and let it toast a little bit I've
made risottos with and without toasting
rice I honestly can't tell a difference
in flavor or texture but I generally
just toast them out of tradition
doesn't really seem to make much of a
difference but you can throw the rice in
a dry pan you know let it toast for a
couple minutes and then the actual
risotto part starts occurring you're
gonna get either water or stock I would
recommend stock chicken stock beef stock
veggie stock really any sort of culinary
stock you won't depending on what else
is going in the dish is perfectly fine
it's gonna let you get more flavor into
the dish you can do this with just water
but I would recommend using stock you
start by adding the stock a little bit
at a time to the pot that you're cooking
your your rice and meat and everything
else in and you just stir it you stir it
constantly you don't have to be super
vigorous about it
just keep it moving around that's going
to help the the rice a start cooking and
B start releasing starch and then when
you don't want to let it get dry looking
but once there's not much obvious water
or stock left in the pan once you can
drag your spatula across the bottom and
it leaves a trail across the pan or the
pot you just add in more stock you keep
stirring and you repeat the process
until the rice is cooked to the doneness
you want it to be so that's basically it
risotto people say is is a challenging
dish and a lot of people find it
intimidating you could mess up your
first risotto I suppose but honestly
it's not a challenging dish to make
especially if you have a decent nonstick
pot the one way that traditionally
people might say you can mess it up is
by adding too much liquid at one time
honestly that's not that big of a deal
as long as you keep it moving the rice
is gonna keep releasing starch and it's
all fine if you add way too much and the
rice gets done while you still have a
lot of liquid left in the mixture you
can just crank the heat up really really
hot drive off the excess liquid pretty
quickly so that's a pretty easy fix you
you don't want to ever let it get too
dry so if it starts getting dry and
starts sticking to the pot
that could be a problem but you know you
make that mistake once and then you know
how to avoid it from there just keep a
little bit more liquid going the whole
time and you want to end it when so this
is hard to describe I guess like
basically you just get an emulsion of
the starch from the rice and all of the
flavor compounds from everything else
you threw in and the liquid from the
stock and it it just feels like a very
silky creamy sauce even though it's
literally just starch and water and you
know if you get it too dry so you know
you could you could pick it up on a
spoon and it maintains its shape it's
probably a little too dry just stir in a
little bit more stock it's fine if it's
too loose like you know if it flows like
a sauce then you probably just want to
keep it simmering a little bit longer
until you get the liquid where you want
it but I mean literally just make one
it's not too hard if if you make it in
you're like ah this doesn't feel as
silky and rich as I want it just add
more liquid next time or pull it with a
little bit more liquid left next time
and if it's like soup if it's incredibly
soupy then just keep that in mind and
just let more of the liquid simmer off
next time you make it and it really is
that easy so it doesn't take that long
to make a good risotto so it's it's a
little bit quicker than a pot of rice I
think generally rice without a rice
cooker I've never used a rice cooker I
should get one but I have they're pretty
cool how long does it take to make rice
in a rice cooker oh I forget I had one
when I was in college my roommate had
one I use it all the time but it's been
it's been ages no it's ours I think oh
wait wait wait I might be wrong I don't
know I I would just make it come back a
very long time later so so when you make
rice and a pan on the stove it takes
about 30 minutes give or take a risotto
will generally be done in about 20
minutes so it is a little bit quicker
you are hands-on the whole time because
you are stirring it the whole time so
that is one thing to note but it's not
it's not something where you're signing
up for
of labor to make a dish so it's not
incredibly labor-intensive it's not
super hard to make if you're making a
risotto to impress someone which again I
should reiterate risottos aren't hard to
make but for whatever reason a lot of
people find them very impressive so this
is a good thing to have in your
repertoire to impress people if you're
trying to impress them and you're you're
cooking for other folks traditional ways
to to finish off a risotto is once
everything gets down to the texture you
wanted or slightly looser like slightly
more wet than you would want to serve it
throw a pretty good amount of some sort
of dry cheese in so generally Parmesan
or pecorino pull it off the heat at that
time just keep it stirring the cheese
will dissolve in it'll emulsify with the
sauce you have going it's absolutely
delicious and then the other thing that
people will typically do to finish a
risotto is to toss in like a tablespoon
or two of butter and stir that in
that'll emulsify in with everything else
just makes it very very rich and
indulgent and if you're making risotto
for someone else who doesn't care about
their macros those are you know great
ways to take it up another notch if
you're trying to make this super macro
friendly I promise you if you make it
without finishing it with cheese and
butter it will still be very good it'll
still be very silky and indulgent
tasting while literally having the same
macros as rice which is absolutely
incredible it'll have more flavor worked
into it because you're making it with
stock instead of water all of the
flavors from the onions garlic meat
whatever else you put in it will be in
there it's all mixed together it's
really really good if you do want to
finish it with a little cheese if you
have like good parmigiano-reggiano it
doesn't take very much at all to kick it
up another notch further without adding
that many additional calories but like I
said just a plain risotto in my opinion
is is a step up from just regular rice
while still having the same macros
uh in you know if you're shut in for a
while and you have a lot of pantry
staples including a bunch of rice and
maybe some chicken stock or beef stock
or veggie stock and you want a new
recipe to play around with try your hand
at a risotto
it's fun it's rewarding it's really good
it can be very macro friendly and I
would highly recommend it a couple
little swaps for you because some of us
are gonna be just stopping by flavortown
on our way to shreds ville so a couple
things you can do is instead of using
rice pick up some rice - cauliflower in
the frozen aisle of the grocery and
there's quite a dilemma because you want
to get you want to get the creaminess
but you don't want to go with the butter
you want to get a little cheesiness mix
in it maybe a little bit of saltiness
take out the butter don't put any cheese
on go with some cottage cheese and
that's gonna give you your creaminess
and a little bit of cheesiness but don't
think what the butter and all the fat
associated with it so rice cauliflower
cottage cheese that now you're cooking
now you're talking risotto
honestly that inspired me a little bit
so I don't do I don't do like swap style
diet food because I mean like dude it's
it's [ __ ] rice like chicken rice is a
bodybuilder staple I wonder if you could
make it with rice cauliflower though so
you would you would still need some some
some sort of starch in it to to kind of
like make the sauce come together
properly use your like horn start what's
this so I was gonna say like a little
cornstarch slurry might get the job done
there and then I want to go cottage
cheese personally I think just based on
the texture you're going for that's more
lasagna risotto I would say like a
ricotta like a low-fat ricotta would
potentially get the job done or even
just for for overall creaminess like a
low-fat cream cheese I'm not
recommending any of this basically I
gave you a good thing too
era gave you a shitty thing to try if
you want to make the shitty version I
think you can make the shitty version a
little bit better I don't know I
one thing I used to do this is a real
thing somebody told me to do it so I
just did it I was young I would strain
my cottage cheese and just have the
curds and like not any of the like
liquid part so straining out the curds
eat the curds those are actually very
good on their own and use the liquidy
part put in your risotto nice and creamy
you uh you literally just gave the first
step of most cheese making processes
well there you go I'm a lot better at
cooking that anyone believes there's a
lot of talent kind of hiding under okay
awesome so I think that does it for this
episode yeah
but we'll be back at some point we're
gonna do some more sporadic episodes
most likely coming up but in any case
take care and we will be back soon
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
you